[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
ihnen allen einen schönen guten abend
tennis und fußball gleich im sport mit
christian otto so ist es guten abend wir
schauen jetzt auf die themen von heute
empörung über russland den lieferstopp
von erdgas nach polen und bulgarien
nennt die eu erpressung moskau droht
auch anderen den gashahn zuzudrehen
entlastung wegen hoher energiepreise die
bundesregierung beschließt
erleichterungen für eltern und
autofahrer sowie einen neuen euro ticket
für den nahverkehr
schwere waffen für die ukraine union und
regierung einigen sich um das
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr wird noch gerungen
die frage der deutschen
energiesicherheit taucht jetzt mit
voller wucht wieder auf nachdem russland
den eu ländern polen und bulgarien quasi
über nacht den gashahn abdrehte fragen
sich viele was wenn präsident putin das
auch auf deutschland ausweiten sollte
politische und wirtschaftliche
reaktionen dazu gleich zuvor volker
dutschek über deutsche gas abhängigkeit
und ströme
auch in deutschland wird erdgas
gefördert wie hier im niedersächsischen
hoch steht allerdings ist der heimische
anteil minimal insgesamt sechs prozent
aus deutschland stehen 94 gasimporten
gegenüber
2020 betrug der import aus den
niederlanden 12,7 prozent aus norwegen
30,6 prozent der anteil aus russland
55,2 prozent
wirtschaftsminister harbeck bezifferte
den aktuellen wert heute auf nur noch 35
prozent weil es gelungen sei die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas zu
reduzieren
den löwenanteil liefert russland den
größten teil über die nord stream 1 zum
pipelinenetz gehörten bisher auch ja mal
bruderschaft und sojus eine wichtige
rolle spielen die gasspeicher sie dienen
als puffer wenn mehr gas verbraucht als
geliefert wird vor einem monat lag der
anteil noch bei rund 25 prozent jetzt
sind es 33 4 prozent
anfang november müssen alle speicher bis
90 prozent gefüllt sein
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
nennt die russischen gas kappungen einen
erpressungsversuch und sicher darf man
sie auch als drohung gegen deutschland
verstehen ein gas lieferstopp jedenfalls
das wurde gerade auch deutlich würde uns
wegen der starken abhängigkeit von
russland ziemlich hart treffen besonders
die industrie bernd benthin mit den
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
reaktionen
durch diese rohre fließt seit heute kein
gas mehr die jamal-pipeline hier an
ihrem endpunkt im brandenburgischen
mallnow für deutschland eher unerheblich
für polen und bulgarien aber die
hauptversorgungsleitung den lieferstopp
jetzt nennt die eu kommissionspräsident
in eine provokation
es ist für uns nicht überraschend dass
der kreml versucht uns mit fossiler
energie zu erpressen wir haben uns aber
darauf vorbereitet
russland begründet seinen schritt damit
dass polen und bulgarien nicht wie
gefordert in rubel gezahlt hätten auch
wir werden nicht in rubel zahlen sagt
der deutsche wirtschaftsminister und
sicherheit den beiden ländern
unterstützung zu das wäre zynisch wenn
deutschland in seiner größe denkt ach so
wie klein kann man noch mal kurz ein
bisschen verprügeln das ist eine warnung
für dich nein es ist realität das ist
die realität wo energie als waffe
eingesetzt wird laut bundesnetzagentur
sei die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland derzeit gewährleistet im
falle eines lieferstopps während
privathaushalte als letztes betroffen
für diesen fall der fälle auf dem man
sich ja gerade vorbereitet um die zu
vermeiden wäre natürlich als erstes die
geschützten verbrauchern im blick zu
nehmen das in private haushalte aber
auch krankenhäuser pflegeheime die wäre
neben geschützte kunden und bei denen
würde ihm kein gas gespart werden die
industrie dagegen fürchtet wenn russland
den gashahn zudreht könnte dass die
deutsche wirtschaft kaum verkraften das
würde massive schäden an der
volkswirtschaftlichen struktur an
unternehmen und damit natürlich auch
generell an beschäftigung an einkommen
an wachstum und steuer auch bedeuten die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas habe
sich bereits verringert sagt die
deutsche regierung trotzdem sei man noch
mindestens zwei jahre auf lieferungen
angewiesen
russlands regierungssprecher paskov
droht jetzt auch anderen ländern mit gas
lieferstopp fragen wer axel sturm in
moskau warum hat sich russland in dieser
phase zu diesem schritt entschlossen
russland macht das aus zwei gründen
natürlich zum einen um macht zu
demonstrieren zum anderen aber vor allen
dingen um den rubel kurs stabil zu
halten zumindest ist das hier die
überlegung die der mechanismus
funktioniert folgendermaßen wenn
russland seine kunden dazu zwingt in
oben zu bezahlen entweder durch
einzahlungen auf ein konto bei der
gazprombank oder direkt dann müssen
rubel besorgt werden devisenhändler also
könnten mehr geld für den rubel
verlangen und das könnte mittelfristig
dazu führen dass der rubel nicht
abstürzt soweit die überlegung
allerdings gibt es hier deutliche
signale dass die sanktionen langsam an
kommen langsam wirken heute gab es
wirtschaftsprognosen die wirtschaft
könnte bis ende des jahres um bis zu
neun prozent einbrechen und die
inflation um bis zu 20 prozent steigen
danke für die hintergründe noch moskau
axel sturm war das ja wie kann
deutschland unabhängiger werden von
russischem gas antworten dazu haben wir
online doch einmal kurz und knapp
zusammengefasst in unserer zdf heute app
was die unterstützung der ukraine mit
schweren waffen angeht will die union
jetzt dem antrag der ampel regierung
folgen morgen soll dies im bundestag
beschlossen werden jetzt stellt sich die
frage ob es auch über das 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen das kanzler scholz
ja zur stärkung von deutschlands
sicherheit ausgerufen hatte eine
einigung geben wird vor wenigen minuten
endete dazu die erste lesung im
bundestag mehr von david gebhard
zeitenwende ist ein großes wort 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr eine
beachtlich große summe und so sind es
auch große worte die der finanzminister
heute wählt um die neuen schulden die
sondervermögen heißen sollen zu
begründen es geht nicht um eine
militarisierung der außenpolitik aber um
eines man muss kämpfen können um nicht
kämpfen zu müssen und deshalb muss die
bundeswehr ertüchtigt werden um das
sondervermögen auf den weg zu bringen
braucht die ampel eine
grundgesetzänderung also eine
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag und
damit stimmen aus der union die knüpft
bedingungen daran etwa das versprechen
das so genannte zwei prozent ziel im
grundgesetz festzuschreiben
seitenwände bedeutet keine einmalzahlung
an die bundeswehr sondern ein
dauerauftrag an unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit wollen wir jedes
jahr wirklich zwei prozent investieren
was es in dem jahr wurde die f35 was ist
was es in dem jahr über die f35 kaufen
da sind es vielleicht mehr als zwei
prozent wollen sie denn das grundgesetz
an diesem tag ändern es gehe vor allem
darum die bündnisfähigkeit zu
gewährleisten die bestands beschreibung
der bundeswehr derzeit ein
offenbarungseid
wir haben zum beispiel auch immer bier
350 schützenpanzer puma
davon sind tatsächlich
150 einsatzbereit beim kampfhubschrauber
tiger sitzt nicht anders aus von 51
maschinen können gerade 9 abheben die
afg kritisiert heute vor allem das
verfahren die konstruktion
sondervermögen die linke lehnt höhere
militärausgaben generell ab die
bundeswehr ist nicht wegen zu wenig geld
kaum einsatzfähig sondern wegen des
grottenschlechten management oder in
dieses schwarze loch in diesen schwarzen
oder einfach weitere milliarden
steuergelder versenkt werden nein die
gespräche zwischen ampel und union
laufen beim thema lieferung schwerer
waffen an die ukraine hat man sich nun
verständigt beim sondervermögen heißt es
sei eine einigung offen
krieg lieferprobleme inflation kein
wunder dass die wirtschaft nicht so
läuft wie erhofft das zeigt auch die
frühjahrsprognose der regierung war man
anfang des jahres noch von 3,6 prozent
wachstum ausgegangen sind es jetzt nur
noch 2,2 prozent wichtig für die
verbraucher die regierung rechnet für
das gesamtjahr mit einer inflationsrate
von 6,1 prozent
ein grund dafür die rasant gestiegenen
energiepreise und um die bürger von
denen zu entlassen also von den
energiepreisen hat das bundeskabinett
jetzt das geplante maßnahmenpaket
beschlossen zentraler punkt ist eine
energiepreis pauschale jeder
erwerbstätige bekommt 300 euro brutto
für jedes kind gibt es einen kinderbonus
100 euro außerdem kommt ein tank rabatt
ein liter benzin soll 30 cent weniger
kosten diese dann 14 cent weniger
ebenfalls drei monate lang gibt es ein
billig ticket im nahverkehr für neun
euro pro monat kritiker bemängeln dass
dies nicht alle gleichermaßen entlastet
peter böhme
hohe preise aller orten nun das
entlastungspaket doch die freude bei
bürgern wie hier in düsseldorf eher
gedämpft
das problem nicht weg dieses paket ist
einmalig und
bezahlen ja eigentlich durchgehend
eigentlich ein bisschen die daran
arbeiten die steuern zu senken am ende
zahlt man drauf davon gehe ich aus
es muss halt nur gerecht sein wie
gerecht ist das paket das deutsche
institut für wirtschaftsforschung hat
nachgerechnet danach würden alle
haushalte auch nach den entlastungen
noch 2,1 prozent mehr zahlen für energie
die einkommensschwächsten zehn prozent
der haushalte jedoch müssten drei
prozent mehr zahlen wir sehen eine hohe
inflation von energie- und
lebensmittelpreisen gleichzeitig wissen
wir dass menschen mit geringen einkommen
ein vielfaches mehr relativ zu ihrem
eigenen einkommen für die energie und
lebensmittel ausgeben im vergleich zu
menschen mit hohem einkommen
kritik kommt von sozialverbänden den
rentnerinnen und rentner gehen bei der
energiepreis pauschale leer aus weil sie
keine einkommensteuer zahlen
menschen mit kleinen renten nix das
finde ich nicht gerecht weitere
entlastungen werden gefordert etwa der
wegfall der mehrwertsteuer bei
lebensmitteln doch der finanzminister
dämpfte heute die erwartungen auf der
anderen seite können wir dauerhaft
steigende weltmarktpreise
nichts mit öffentlichen mitteln
ausgleichen
wir können wirtschaftliche härten
abfedern aber das alles hat den
charakter eines stoßdämpfers der
stoßdämpfer ist einmalig angedacht die
hohen preise werden bleiben
und jetzt schauen wir in die ukraine
russland hat nach eigenen angaben eine
zitat große menge westlicher waffen in
der ukraine zerstört was die ukraine
dementiert außerdem betonte präsident
putin dass seine truppen alle gesteckten
ziele erreichen werden die offensive im
osten der ukraine geht weiter mehrere
ortschaften seien erobert worden meldet
das russische militär tobias häfner
berichtet
ukraine und rosen völkerfreundschaft und
verbundenheit sollte dieses monument in
kiew schon zu sowjetzeiten
symbolisieren nun will es niemand mehr
haben der montage in anwesenheit von
bürgermeister klitschko
in der ost ukraine wie der russische
vorstoß auch auf dem land immer
spürbarer dort wo ali anna und andré
aussehen ist die frontlinie nur 20
kilometer entfernt
wir haben angst dass sie uns töten
überall fliegen raketen und andere
geschosse
das russische militär veröffentlicht
heute teils grausame bilder die tote
ukrainische truppen in ihren stellungen
zeigen sollen zudem aufnahmen von waffen
die man den ukrainern abgenommen haben
will
pfizer policia werde russland auch
lagerhallen mit waffen zerstört haben
die der westen an die ukraine geliefert
hatte und wieder droht präsident putin
wer sich in unserem militär operation
einmischt sollte wissen dass wir auf
diese bedrohung blitzschnell mit
gegenmaßnahmen reagieren werden
maßnahmen mit denen russland nicht
prahlt sondern sie einfach anwendet
sagte er vor einem regionalparlament
russische gräueltaten soll dieses video
von mitte märz belegen veröffentlicht
vom us senders cnn zu sehen demnach
russische truppen in der nähe von
leichen in butter bei kiew in den po im
zentrum des landes sammeln sich immer
mehr flüchtlinge und sie wägen ab hier
bleiben oder noch weiterziehen in
richtung westen
ja so viel zum thema ukraine die eu
kommission macht ernst und hat heute
offiziell ein verfahren gegen ungarn
gestartet wegen möglicher verstöße gegen
rechtsstaatliche prinzipien es geht
unter anderem um korruption am ende des
verfahrens droht ungarn die kürzung von
eu geldern und dabei geht es um viele
milliarden euro
die korona regeln für urlaubsrückkehrer
werden bis ende mai verlängert das
entschied die bundesregierung somit
müssen ein reisende nach deutschland ab
12 jahren weiter einen 3g nachweis
vorzeigen als geimpft gewesen oder
getestet die aktuellen corona zahlen das
rki meldet 141 1661 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden 56
1922 weniger als vor einer woche
343 neue todesfälle kamen hinzu die
sieben tage incident sinken nun auf 8
187,6
sie wissen in deutschland gibt es zu
wenig bezahlbaren wohnraum auf der suche
nach einer lösung haben sich politiker
baubranche und andere
interessenvertreter heute
zusammengesetzt bauministerin klara
geywitz will an ihrem ehrgeizigen ziel
fest halten nämlich 400.000 neue
wohnungen jährlich und davon 100.000 im
sozialen wohnungsbau möglichst in den
städten aber die baukosten schießen
immer weiter in die höhe und das ist
nicht die einzige schwierigkeit wie
jetzt roman leskovar berichtet
99 wohnungen entstehen hier in
berlin-treptow gebaut von einer berliner
genossenschaft bezahlbare wohnen fühlt
man sich verpflichtet zwischen elf und
zwölf euro pro quadratmeter sind geplagt
aktuelle projekte will man noch
fertigstellen neue sind vorerst nicht
geplant weil wir im augenblick sehr hohe
grundstückspreise hohe baukosten die
ständig weiter steigen haben und jetzt
kommt auch noch hinzu dass seit dezember
massiver zinsanstieg zu verzeichnen ist
schwierige bedingungen zum start des
bündnisses für bezahlbaren wohnraum die
explodierenden baukosten durch die
ukraine krieg überschatten die große
runde darunter politik bauwirtschaft
mieter und umweltverbände sie sollen die
voraussetzungen für 400.000 neue
wohnungen jährlich schaffen die
ministerin hält am ziel fest ja die
rahmenbedingungen sind schwieriger
geworden aber natürlich dürfen wir
angesichts des bedarfes nicht das ziel
in abrede stellen die vielen
interessensgruppen eine zusätzliche
herausforderung für mehr bautätigkeit
die forderungen reichen von
bürokratieabbau mehr umweltschutz oder
mieten regulierung der mieterbund
jedenfalls macht deutlich nicht nur über
neubau reden zu wollen wir brauchen
neben dem neubau vor allen dingen
schwerpunkt auf den bau von
sozialwohnungen und wir brauchen einen
mietpreis begrenzung damit auch
wohnungen im bestand bezahlbar bleiben
viel zu tun für das bündnis also im
herbst soll ein maßnahmenpaket
vorgestellt werden auch die berliner
genossenschaft hofft dann auf bessere
bedingungen
wir sind beim sport und ich ärger mich
wirklich richtig dass ich fußball
spielen so nahmen nicht gesehen habe und
das soll historisch gewesen dann sagt
sogar etwas für die geschichtsbücher
4 zu 3 zwischen manchester city und real
madrid im hinspiel der halt das im
halbfinal-hinspiel so ist's richtig der
champions league begeistert die
fußballszene wahnsinn unglaublich
einfach verrückt sind drei der vielen
superlative seit abpfiff
pep guardiola und carlo ancelotti nach
einem mitreißenden ersten halbfinale als
manchester city bereits in der elften
minute durch gabriel jesus auf 20 erhöht
spricht alles für den englischen meister
doch real madrid hat ja karim benzema
sein 221 lässt die königlichen wieder
ans finale glauben nach je einem
weiteren treffer zum 3 2 stellt silber
den alten zwei-tore-abstand für city
wieder her 4 zu 2 74 minute doch dann
verursacht laporte einen handelfmeter
die ihn verwandelt bands immer mit
aufreizender lässigkeit zum 4 3-endstand
gute karten nun also für real vor dem
rückspiel kommenden mittwoch in madrid
und ausführliche highlights stimmen und
analysen auch vom zweiten halbfinal
hinspiel der königsklasse fc liverpool
gegen bayern-bezwinger villarreal von 23
uhr an hier bei uns im zdf in der
vorschlussrunde der europa league sind
morgen abend zwei deutsche vereine
gefordert eintracht frankfurt vor bei
west ham united und er bleibt sich hat
zuerst heimvorteil
normalerweise zählt dieser mann er zudem
beherrschten emotionen zeigt ja nur wenn
sein fußball-herz sich überschlägt
domenico tedesco hat großes vor will mit
leipzig zwei titel holen im finale des
dfb pokals stehen die sachsen bereits
morgen soll im halbfinal hinspiel der
europa league gegen glasgow ein weiteres
highlight folgen wohl wissend dass es
schwer ist das ist hat der arbeit ist
und das wahrscheinlich am donnerstag
ja das ding bei weitem nicht entschieden
ist dass sich dann in glasgow
entscheiden wird die favoritenrollen
nehmen die leipziger an unterschätzen
aber gleichzeitig nicht die gäste aus
schottland die bereits dortmund aus dem
wettbewerb gekickt haben
enttäuschend frühes aus für tennis profi
alexander zverev beim atp-turnier in
münchen gegen den erst 18 jahre alten
dänen holger ohne verlor er sein auftakt
match mit 3 6 und 2 6 danach war zverev
das publikum umgebung für eines zitat
bodenlose leistung gegen die frühere
nummer 1 der junioren weltrangliste und
letzter deutscher ist nun aus karotte im
einzelnen dann vielen dank christin wir
schauen zum schluss noch mal kurz ins
all genauer zur iss da heißt es nämlich
schichtwechsel eine neue crew aus den
usa und italien drei frauen und ein mann
sind auf dem weg zur weltraum wg sie
lösen das team des deutschen matthias
maurer ab der hat sechs monate und mehr
als 2.500 erdumrundungen hinter sich und
freut sich jetzt wie er sagt auf
frischen salat und pizza und die kriegt
man auf der erde sicher knuspriger hin
als da oben stellte ich mir zumindest
vor so bleiben noch diese irdischen
glückszahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten 3
17 19 25 40 46 und die superzahl 8
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite 557 für
die meisten morgen viel sonne scheint
mehr dazu gleich beim wetter von westen
tel friedrich merz der
unionsfraktionschef später im interview
mit christian sievers im heute-journal
ab 21 uhr 45 das gesamte heute 19 team
sagt danke fürs zuschauen schönen abend
und bis morgen um 7
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hoher luftdruck
hat sich nun durchgesetzt und die
letzten schauer haben sich auch verzogen
und das mit diesem umfangreichen hoch
aber auf seiner ostseite kommt durchaus
kühle luft mit und das spüren wir
besonders an den küsten einige wolken
sind dann auch dabei zum beispiel da
kommen da nachts im osten also nicht
ganz so ungetrübt wie im westen und im
süden in gewässernähe bildet sich auch
nebel die temperaturen sinken dabei am
tiefsten an den alpen auf 0 grad sonst
ein grad im vogtland sowie im nordwesten
sieben grad gibt es im rhein main gebiet
morgen dann ungetrübter sonnenschein
ganz im westen und auch nach süden sonst
sind die wolken auch mal kompakte aber
insgesamt trockenes wetter bei höchsten
temperaturen von 12 bis 14 grad also im
norden merkt man durchaus die kühlere
luft die daher an strömt ansonsten 20
bis 23 grad die höchsten werte im
südwesten die kommenden tage am freitag
ist es noch trocken aber die wolken
nehmen durchaus zu 11 bis 22 grad
spitzen es am samstag dann schauer und
gewitter im süden sowie sonntag und ein
wenig kühler damit ein schöner abend